so uh album on the way the four pack is
out now
you got a song with Larry June yeah
who's been killing [__]
um how long have you been hip to Larry's
movement because he's been yeah for the
better part of the last 10 years
building an independent Powerhouse right
I actually got put on The Late John from
from Vic hmm yeah he put me onto his
music and I really just liked how he
branded everything his aesthetic the
organic it's all very consistent yours
is too though you guys are very
purposeful in terms of The Branding and
the aesthetic of all your I feel like
all your art everything just flows
together right and I feel like it was
only right and I pay attention to the
comments too as far as like with the
fans be wanting from me and stuff and
they always preached about lady June I
got a heavy fan base in the bay
so it was perfect you guys do a swap no
we didn't we didn't not yet you gotta do
one for him now oh yeah that's
inevitable we definitely gonna cook up
some more even he just be he just popped
out of my uh Jay's residency at the vet
in Vegas right I forgot you're doing
trades now yeah you're rich
what are we talking about you're it you
gotta drink they don't be giving Dre's
residencies to know lightweights out
here we building the relationships
that's all I could say how is it like
doing because I I've been to Dre's a
million times
and when you perform at Dre's you're
performing for your fans but you're also
performing for just like tourists that
are in town right so is it different
like when you do a Dre show like how
because is it kind of like doing a club
show or is it because it's like writing
yeah it's like that pocket right in the
middle of a like an actual show in a
club show but the crowd it felt like it
was nothing but blacks fans up in there
the way they were screaming word for
word how often are you doing it well we
just did the first one
um earlier this year I have another
Resident residency out there right now
daylight but we cooking up right now
we're just building a relationship for
the most part you gamble when you're in
Vegas
slightly I'll be at the tables what do
you play though I'll shoot crabs crabs
is the best funnest game yeah you could
win really it's not fun when you're
losing though because you could lose
fast exactly man crap so yeah yo you'll
be [__] on a run and they'd be like
let me buy all the [__] numbers yeah
that's seven inch I'm still yeah I'm
still a student though so I you know I
play you know who's really good at craps
who taught me was DJ head he's a
degenerate Gambler he would never let
him not picture him gambling of course
not because he's perfect but he is a he
that is his one black market we got
something on him he's a gambler yeah
[__] got the crap table it's
like watching Tiger Woods play golf
that's crazy I I just I never knew how
to play crabs until me and head went to
Vegas and it was like watching art yeah
he's amazing at craps I don't know if
you could be good at craps but he was
yeah yeah craps is fun that's great I
cannot picture DJ head gambling